I'm just gonna stay inside of here
because I don't really want to be seen
right now I just was at the Apple store
woke up at like 2 o'clock in the morning
to be one of the first dish sort of in
line because I saw yesterday there's
about 40 people in line at 10 o'clock
p.m. yesterday in line for their iPhone
just got in line last night I can't see
your face but I know it's next we're
gonna unbox the iPhone 5s slate there
was no white or gold to be available in
any AT&T carrier service at one of the
biggest Apple stores in California so it
was very very very sad no other goal
line if I can get to go I'll get I'm
actually gonna come out of my hood now
so here's a line see I want this to be
me then I'm excited to get my hands on
this little guy and of course there's a
30-day return policy so I plan on
ordering the gold one and hopefully I'll
be able to return this one here it is
iPhone 5s in slight gray the survey that
I did was absolutely overwhelming with
the amount of goals for the gold phone
which hopefully I'll be able to get soon
but this is this light gray it is in
fact quite slate as you can tell it's
like it almost looks kind of like the
silver and to be completely honest with
you I could hardly even tell the
difference between the silver and the
gold the gold is super not gold doll I
know which what it is
this is not gold it's now that gold it
doesn't even look gold so in comparison
here is the silver here is the slate
because the slate is actually almost the
same color as this silver and it should
be already activated and ready to go
because I did activate it in store
Justine slowly waiting for the process
here as she is very disappointed was not
able to get a iPhone white hair that you
really want to I call backup please show
you what's inside this box and I'm in a
hurry because I have to get on a flight
in 25 minutes
headphones you got your little power
jack you've got another lightning cable
all of the things that you're going to
need I don't actually estimate faster
give me my phone please
Oh touch ID here we go here we go okay
what is what are you telling me you will
make it set up now scan the finger or
thumb you normally use on the home
button that's what I'm doing
there's so many things that's asking for
right now
well it's restoring all of my apps which
is not that important the real thing is
Siri why did Apple not make enough
iPhones today that I'm stuck with the
slate gray and not the gold or the
silver checking my web search turned
this on oh my gosh it really works ready
so the other cool thing that I'm pretty
excited about is the dual LED flashes so
that when you take a picture with a
flash I think everyone knows how awful
the iPhone flash used to be it has two
different one so it'll color correct so
you don't look like a ghost there's a
thing that I didn't touch on in my last
video you can change series voice to a
man so that's uh this is pretty much the
new the new iPhone 5s they have so many
five C's at the Apple Store but not
enough
of the esses I did get a chance to check
them out at the Apple Store and they
kind of felt pretty cool I was actually
quite impressed and I'm not sure why
this phone is so hot right now like it
is burning up what's wrong with you
little guys you having some struggles
that was just a quick unboxing and a
little look at the iPhone slate-gray
don't call it black because the iPhone
store will have a heart attack if you
walk in there asking for the black
iPhone that's it for me stay tuned for
an apple pie that I'm cooking
dedicated to the gold iPhone I have to
finish editing it but what for that even
today or tomorrow and I will see you
guys soon with umm my face on your
screen and videos I need to go to sleep
too good have to get on planes I'll see
you guys later thanks for watching bye